Det finns ju en jäkla massa fördelar att ha ont om plattor, då börjar det optimera på riktigt.
Ja herregud, ja du pratar som en sån.
Ja men det är ju ganska enkelt, får du inte plats med det än, då får du göra plats.
Då är det liksom okej, det här har suttit på hyllan i ett år.
Inte en nackdel, det är en utmaning, ja.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl generationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkommen till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Idag välkomnar vi Emil på Ställningsprodukter.
Vissa avsnitt är gjorda för lyssnaren, men vissa avsnitt är gjorda för mig.
Jag är ju djupt fascinerad av bedröblig logistik, så jag har varit här på morgonen och kikat in deras lager.
Det är kanske ett av de få lagren i Sverige som har det krångligare pack och plock än vad vi har.
Jag har glatt mig och gått runt här och mått bra över att andra lider mer.
Så med det är en trots och välkommen till podden Emil.
Tacka tacka, tacka tacka.
Stämmer det att ni ständigt har huvudvärk över logistiken?
Ni skickar ju precis skitjobbiga grejer.
Det stämmer jättebra.
Det är verkligen skitjobbiga grejer att skicka.
Det är ju så blandat hela tiden, men jag förklarar det före det där nere.
Det är ju som ett plockepinn med lego som kan packas på miljarders olika sätt och det är ju olika grejer hela tiden.
Det blir ju utmanande i logistiken.
Ni säljer ju liksom allt från hjälmar upp till stora ställningar till långa jävla stegar, till, ja det är ju bara bedrövligt att skicka.
Ja, men det är för jävligt.
Jag har väl konstant dialog med diverse fraktbolag hela tiden på att se hur kan vi lösa det här.
Vad har vi för alternativ med att kunna packa saker på olika sätt och hur kan vi optimera flak ytan på lastbilen så att vi får så billigt pris som möjligt och att de får in så mycket som möjligt.
För det som jag tycker var lite intressant, vi ska gå in sen på vad ni egentligen gör och vem du är och allt sånt där men men detta är så fascinerande.
Du visade därute att ni liksom platsbygger pallarna.
Ni liksom snickrar en pall runt utrustningen.
Det har jag aldrig sett förut.
Nej och vi är jäkligt kostnadsmedvetna.
Och när man ser till vår lag och personal oss själva så vill vi gärna att man snickar bakgrund nästan.
För att det är så mycket anpassningar av Colin delvis för att få ner faktvolumen och flakmeterna så mycket som möjligt men också för att kunna packa det på ett så säkert sätt som möjligt.
Vi säljer ju stål och aluminiumprodukter, det är inte så jäkla känsligt.
Det är liksom inga inredningsprodukter som folk returnerar för att de är repiga.
Så det tål ju lite stryk men det är ändå lätt att det är transportskada som man inte packar ordentligt.
Så där hittar vi nya sätt i princip varje dag på att packa saker och ting.
Nu har vi ändå etablerats oss över ett tag, och hittat hyfsat standardiserade processer.
Men det senaste veckan hittade vi ett ännu bättre sätt att packa en grej som vi har skickat säkert 300-400 stycken av.
Det var faktiskt rätt häftigt att se att ni liksom, hur stor skillnad kan det göra för någon som inte är insatt.
För det som vi var nere och kikade på nu var, det var ju någon sorts ställning som man bygger upp.
Och istället för att lägga den plant på pall, så som jag tänker att man lägger den enligt någon sorts mackprincip, så lägger ni den i en liten macka på sidokant, för då får ni en mindre volymyta då.
Ajamän, liksom längden går ju sällan att göra någonting åt på produkterna, de är ju så långa som de är.
Men du kan antingen lägga dem rent plats som en macka som du säger, och då är de ganska breda, och då tar de i myta, men du kan också ställa dem på högkant.
Och det är det vi gör på mycket av våra kollin, att vi ställer dem på högkant, och det finns ju liksom inget standardiserad pall för att ställa saker på högkant.
Så vi köper in reglar och brädor, och bygger som uformade delar där vi måttanpassar dem för varje kolli.
Det tar lite längre tid att göra det, men vi har ändå hyfsat standardiserade mått för vissa grejer så vi kan bli förberedda när vi har lite att göra.
Gör ett gäng sådana här un då som vi kallar det, så man bara kan döna ner när det väl är bråttom.
Men sen är det ju också ställning, vi säljer ju ett ställningspaket, och i varje paket så finns det ju 41 olika valalternativ, så du kan ju välja och få den på miljarders olika sätt.
Och då anpassas ju måtten efter vad du väljer, för det är olika mycket delar.
För det var också en av de här fascinerande grejerna vi gick där, att ni säljer ju liksom, ni säljer ju givetvis paket också, men kunden kan liksom plocka olika saker, det är två stycken sådana beslag, tre stycken sådana grejer, det är fyra sådana där, det är en jävla packprocess och hur man ska få in det sen.
Det går ju inte att förbereda på samma sätt, vi säljer halvt ett paket, 29 kilo, då vet vi att vi packar det på det här sättet och vi förbereder det på det här sättet, ni gör ju inte så liksom.
Nej, det går inte med något egentligen, det är som ett lego där man plockar ihop det man vill ha själv, och sen har vi ju som sagt satt ihop färdiga paketer på sätt som vi rekommenderar att bygga det, men i de färdiga sättet så är det ändå en mängd olika valatnader där du kan välja olika sätt, och så ja det är komplext i min sätt.
För er som lyssnar nu så kan ni ju, om ni inte vill lyssna på logistik och packproblem, så kan ni hoppa fram till den sista minuten i podden och lyssna när vi går igenom Emils privatliv, för nu blir det 59 minuter logistik här.
Vi har en fråga till varandra för det här, ni säger ju även stegar, det går inte att göra lönsamt eller?
Jo, alltså, det är ju typ de stegarna som vi såg där nere, ni hade en liten smal stege som var typ, kan den vara tre meter eller någonting?
Den är nog fyra meter.
Fyra meter.
Vad skickar, hur är det?
Det är samma där, den är ju fyra meter lång, 60 centimeter bred.
Vi kan inte ställa den upp liksom.
Nej, vi kan inte ställa den upp, men är den kortare än 260, då kan vi boka den ståendes.
Så vi försöker liksom optimera stegar och sånt, så att de helst inte är längre än 260, men det går ju bara till en viss grad.
Med de här fyra meter stegarna så ställer vi dem på högkant, det vill säga att de blir fyra meter långa.
Vi hade kunnat lägga dem så att de är 60 breda, men vi ställer dem på högkant på sidan så att de blir 15 centimeter breda.
Bara där kan ni skilja en tuselapp i fraktpris.
Sen sitter vi också manuellt, våra lagepersonaler även vi är på kontoret, sitter och jämför med ett gäng olika fraktbolag, ser vilka som är billigaste just i den orten.
Ni har inget standardiserat fraktbolag eller några olika, utan ni sitter och jämför?
Vi har avtal med tre olika.
Det är liksom Postno, det är för alla smågrejer, och så har vi två andra på större grejer.
Jag sitter nu de senaste veckorna med ett gäng olika också, för jag vill bara få in fler här så jag har fler att välja på.
Vill fraktbolagen ha er som kunder?
Du vet.
Vi omsätter ju väldigt mycket på frakter, för det skickar ju stora grejer, det är ju dyra frakter.
Och vi tar ju betalt för vad det kostar oftast.
I vissa fall, just stegar gör vi inte det utan det får käka på marginalen, men alla andra produkter tar vi oftast betalt för vad det kostar.
Och det är ju så vi har jobbat från start och våra kunder accepterar det.
Sen har vi ju absolut experimenterat med att subventionera frakter mot att baka in det i marginalen och hela den biten.
Och det ökar ju konvertering, det är ju inget snack om saken, men då blir det lite oskyst mot våra Göteborgs kunder.
Ja, jag bara tänker, jag bara vet hur, vi har ju använt skänker, men vi har även använt Bling och D&L och liknande och DSV och liknande genom åren och sånt där men, alltså det är en grej att sitta i säljssamtal med säljaren och bara, ja men här ni ska få frakter för tio miljoner typ.
Men det är en helt annan grej när chaufförerna kommer ut och bara, ja okej, vad är det mina typ tolvpall, ja det är inte tolvpall, det är tre fucking stegar.
Det är fyra stycken weirdo-collins som du inte kan få in på bredd.
Den här måste du dra in från sidan med en truck.
De är inte jätte, är ni råntygt enig av lower level chaufförer?
Tom, Tom kan inte gilla er alltså.
Det lokala åkeriet.
Ja, nej det är ju, jag tror vi har något litet rykte här i stan, att det är jävligt jobbigt att lasta oss oss.
Men grejen är, de fack-bolagen vi jobbar med för de stora grejerna, det är ju sådana som är specialiserade på de här grejerna.
De jobbar ju mycket mot byggbranschen, bara för att autonora så är det ju en tex och kollubi i två liksom, och det känner man inte igen som en e-handlare så, utan byggbranschen känner igen det mer.
Och de är mer flexibla där, vi kan göra en prisfråga i deras verktyg med ett knapptryck och få exakt vad det kostar oss.
Och det gör ju att vi kan beräkna det mycket mer skarpt, och göra att vi kan gå breakeven på i princip alla våra faktor.
Och det är ju avgörande för sista raden i sluthanden.
Ja, det är ju sjukt faktiskt att ni lyckas med det.
Alcred.
Nu kan vi gå tillbaks till, hej Emil, vad trevligt att ha dig här.
Vem, ni driver ju ställningsprodukter, och jag säger ni för ni är ett familjeföretag.
Stämmer.
Jag träffade din farsa härute, och jag träffade din bror, och din mamma har jag inte träffat, men hon var här och lämnade två hundar.
Så jag har träffat hundarna.
Hur är det att jobba med hela, är det hela familjen?
Nej, vi är fem bröder så jag har ju en gäng till, men de är också inom byggbranschen men inte involverade här.
Så vi är en stor familj.
Men är du äldst då?
Nej.
Jag är yngst.
Du är yngst, okej.
Så de stora, de äldre bröderna, de flög själva och gjorde sin grej, och du fick tröstas in, du fick ta det spott.
Ja, lite så.
Jag är väl den enda med en utbildning också.
Jaha, snyggt.
Shout out till brorsen där.
Ja, bäst förutsättningar när föräldrarna är lite äldre.
Jag fattar, jag fattar.
Det var roligt.
Men hur gick det till för dig att komma in i bolaget?
Kan du inte dra, fick du börja här som tolvåring?
Nej, farsan då Ulf, som jag benämner han i jobbsifta, han är ju Ulf här.
Du säger inte pappa här.
Nej nej, han är Ulf här liksom.
Han började ju på det här och spesat på det här 2018.
Han har en lång bakgrund inom utbildningsbranschen och drivit företag där framförallt, sådär som exit och hela den biten.
Så det var han som startade detta?
Ja, ihop med en dåvarande kompanjon som inte är kvar längre.
Och long story short så hade han även ett utbildningsföretag samtidigt som hans kompanjon drev och så finansierade ju upp ställningsproduktets start och hela den biten.
Och där kommer jag ju med en bakgrund från utbildningsbranschen där själv har hytt ut grejer och vet hur svårt det är att få tag i prisvärda produkter och hela den biten.
Så då känner jag att nu ska jag hitta agenturer för att kunna sälja de här produkterna väldigt prisvärt över nätet till framförallt uthyrare.
Det var ju liksom första ursprungstanken.
Det måste ha varit en av de tidigare som gjorde...
Logistiken är ju skitkring detta.
Så det är ju inte den första e-handelsprodukten på marknaden.
Det är ju inte böcker liksom.
Nej, nej det är komplex men det finns.
Vi har konkurrens som funnits längre än oss på rent och sälja ställning liksom.
Men 2018 började han spesa på det, byggde upp det successivt och sen kom ju pandemin 2020 och då hoppade jag på en utbildning på IOM, e-commerce manager, fräcktitel, gav jättemycket egentligen men då såg jag ju till.
Jag har alltid undrat vad man lär sig på de här utbildningarna.
Vad gör man som e-commerce manager?
Vad är det?
Det låter ju fräckare vad det är men man får väl grundkunskaper generellt inom E&M.
Det är liksom SEO, SCM, lite influence, marketing och hela den biten med också.
Sen är det ju basgrejer inom ekonomi, logistik, liksom inkoterms och hela de här bitarna.
Så det är en bra grundutbildning men framförallt är det ju mycket praktik och liksom en direktkontakt med folk inom branschen då.
För det är liksom inga lärare som på en vanlig högskola som har liksom lektorer eller liknande, utan det här är ju folk från branschen som vill lära ut det de kan.
Så det är inte alltid att de är superpedagogiska men de är jävligt kunniga.
Har du nåt sånt riktigt, hade ni nån riktigt usel lärare som bara var...
Ja, helften var väl...
Det är alltså kassan på att lära ut, de var ju duktiga på det område, men kan man inte kommunicera ut det så är det ju var det är.
Men det är mycket en sådan utbildning som det påverkas av hur engagerar du dig själv.
Och jag är ju den generationen som kanske kan flytande Google, som brukar säga att jag söker mig fram lösningar på problem.
Och det är det jag namnar i utbildningen och kunde sätta in mycket av det man lärde sig i utbildningen direkt i ett verkligt case på ställningsprodukter.
Och framförallt göra varenda misstag som finns i boken när man är ungo, rumm och naiv och i början av ett företag liksom så.
Men det var en enda möjlighet för mig att kunna sätta allting i något verkligt och det gynnade ju bolaget också.
Så visar det sig, för det var ju 2020 som det började ta fram.
Men då hade du redan jobbat här?
Nej, jag hade jobbat på bolaget Breve som hydde ut och byggde ställningar.
Så jag har i bakgrund av vad som har jobbat och byggt ställningar och fallskjut.
Jag är liksom hands on, många av våra kunder jag vet ju vad de gör på dagarna så att säga, jag har gjort det själv.
Men jag har varit ute och jobbat lite i Österrike och som resigard och lite sådana här grejer inom mellan.
Som man gör när man är ung och visar.
Men det är ändå nice, då har du ändå den riktiga bakgrund.
Det är ändå, vad ska man säga, vissa jobb är ju sådana att man blir inte respekterad av kunden om man inte själv vet vad de gör.
Och detta är ju ett sådant jobb kan jag bara tänka mig.
Det är såhär, ja du ska köpa det här och det här, absolut, men du har inte varit därute, de här blir man kalliga, alltså det här är skit.
Men när man kan snacka det så är det ju en helt annan grej.
Okej, så du började efter covid då eller under covid?
Ja, jag fick ju inte löne från ställningsprodukter, utan det andra bolaget betalade ut min löne fortfarande, så det var ju liksom ingenting mer än att vi sålde grejer och vi började få fart på grejerna, men det var liksom inte självförsörjande än när jag hoppade på.
Men sen kom ju covidboomen och då tog det fart.
Ja, ni tog fart under, det känns som det borde vara...
Privatpersoner.
Ja, okej.
Renovera hemma.
Du bygger gym hemma, det kör du säkert igen.
Ja, exakt, ja vi hade ju den boven.
I stället för att lägga hundratusen på en Thailandsresa över julen så la de hundratusen på att måla, byta fasad och byta tak och hela den biten.
Ja, för du sa här innan att ni har ungefär hälften ordrar till privatpersoner och hälften till företag, och det känns ju bara såhär spontant skumt.
Är vi så jävla händiga att folk köper en jävla ställning?
De som är smarta, säger jag, som fattar att det är jävligt mycket dyrare oftast att hyra.
För att ska du hyra grejerna så står du där när det regnar och du inte kan använda den när du ska måla din fasad.
Men gör du en liten enkel kalkyl så ser du att det oftast lönar sig att betala.
Och sen, de som handlar, det är ju gårdjägare, det är ju liksom övre medelflask.
Men köper bostadsrättförening, jag tänker att vi bor i ett, de kallar det för en samfälldhet, liksom vid ett stort kvarter då.
Köper sådana människor?
Definitivt.
Där är det ju logiskt liksom.
Ja, men definitivt.
Det är ju allt ifrån föreningar till företag, till privatpersoner, till myndigheter, köper ju massa grejer och det är ju väldigt spritt.
Vi säljer till alla som vill köpa liksom.
Det är ju flera vad man tror som har behov av de här produkterna och marknaden är ju skitstor.
Men mycket är ett djup av Bauhaus och de här lokala som säljer det.
Men de är ju inte experter på grejerna utan de har ju bredd snarare än expertis.
Ja, kan vi inte, vi kan hamna där lite grann.
Ni omsätter väl ish 50 miljoner och har gjort här två år i rad.
Har jag typ rätt eller?
Ja, ink moms 50, lite över 50 men ex moms är lilla 40, 40 eller 50.
Man får räkna hur man vill det som låter coolast.
Men jag tycker alltid att det är så skit att man måste säga alla siffror ex moms för att när jag ska förklara för min mamma hur jävla cool jag är, då vill jag ju säga ink moms för det låter mycket bättre men för du omsätter över 100 miljoner?
Ja, då omsätter jag över 100 miljoner.
För jag får vänta något år innan det är på riktigt.
Men okej, hur tävlar man mot de här monströsa byggvaruhusen?
Hur fan gör man liksom?
Vad är er grej?
Hur ska ni?
Alltså, expertis är en grej.
För vi är ju experter på produkterna.
Ringer du om till Baua och så vill du ha teknisk rådgivning om hur mycket ställning de ska ha, så finns det ingen som kan svara på det.
Ringer du om till oss så kan vi allihopa svara på det och vilka är de exakt vad de behöver för sitt projekt.
Och det försöker vi även skapa så att det är automatiskt.
Man får all den informationen via hemsidan, mycket genom videos och mycket beskrivningar.
Vi har väldigt mycket artiklar i vår kunskapsbank, hur du bygger en ställning, varför du ska köpa en ställning istället för att hyra.
Mycket info som vi försöker samla för att göra det så lätt för kunden som möjligt och göra köpet.
För det är ju väldigt svåra grejer.
Har du aldrig byggt ställning innan så är det inte jättelätt.
Men kikar du in på en video och läser vår guide så kommer du lösa att bygga en ställning.
Och de som handlar hos oss är ju en av sådana som tar saken i egna händer och vill göra det själv.
Men säljer ni samma varumärken som de stora kedjorna?
Nej, det är också lite lustigt.
Byggbranschen, det finns ju ett gäng varumärken i byggbranschen som många känner till och som alla säljer och då hamnar man i det träsket där du inte tjänar några pengar och alla säljer och du konkurrerar mot folk som har betydligt bättre fraktvillkor och kan sälja det betydligt billigare för att de har bättre marginaler i volymer liksom, men så vi jobbar är att vi försöker hitta ditt underdogs inom branschen som gör produkterna där vi får agenturen för produkterna och de tillverkar produkterna som är minst lika bra om inte bättre men till en bra del av priset.
Och det låter lite utopiskt men det är exakt så det fungerar.
Vi hittar mindre fabriker, mindre agenturer som vi får sälja som ingen annan säljer, det är oftast inte hela Norden.
Och då får vi stort förtroende, vi får väldigt bra priser och vi kan sälja bra produkter till lågt pris.
Men det ställer också krav på oss att vi får köpa in till större volymer, vi får göra mycket förarbete själva med att översätta manualer och hela den biten.
Men i slutändan så gör det ju många procent.
Det gör det.
För hur är det?
Jag bara intalar, för ni säger ju även fallskyddsprodukter och selar och sånt där, det måste vara en jävla säkerhetsprocess.
Och om detta är varumärken till exempel som inte är standardiserad, eller du vet såhär, jag köper i alla varor så att kunden känner inte till det.
Hur går liksom processen till för att visa att det här är en riktig produkt som håller för att du ramlar?
Jag vet ju inte hur det funkar men...
Det är inte så svårt som man tror, och nu ska inte alla börja sälja selar bara för jag säger att det är ganska enkelt, men det finns ju standarder, europastandarder som de måste följa, och då måste de göra tester enligt vissa principer.
Men det är inte er problem, det är deras problem.
Så vi ställer ju det kravet på leverantören, och det måste göras av ett liksom oberoende, och vi har krederat testorgan som är behöriga, och det finns en lång lista av dem som får göra det.
Och då hamnar det ju en databas, så det är ganska enkelt att se om det är gjort eller inte.
Så sätt är det ganska enkelt, men det kommer ju med massa svårigheter ändå med att översätta manualer, och säkställ att det är den produkten man faktiskt vill ha, och hela den biten.
Så det är ju utmaningar, det finns en anledning att inte alla gör det.
För det är ju inte lätt, men gör man det bra så kan man ju tjäna pengar.
Men funkar alla produkter så, eller är det bara det som man sitter fast i, alltså selar och liner och sånt, eller funkar det även ställningar så att man måste testa?
Allt vi säljer är mer eller mindre säkerhetsprodukter, visst vi säljer ju arbetshandskor och sådär, det är ju inte lika hårda krav.
Även stegar och sånt.
Ja, det går igenom tester av oberoende, det är ju en akrederad testorgan, och där är det ju, du har kommit undan det.
Du kan sälja utan också, men du får ju inte.
Men det är också en kvalitetsstämpel på att grejerna uppnår de kraven som är.
Det är ju det kunderna kollar efter, snarare än varumärken.
Det är ju inte så jätteetablerat på vår marknad med vissa varumärken, det är därför vi inte ser en jättestor uspiga ta en massa fräcka varumärken.
Vi har varit inne på det många gånger och bara shit ska vi ta in det här varumärket och sen får de köpa vår egna istället.
Men det är väl andra än det att nej, vi vill jobba stenart för att pusha ut våra egna agenturer, våra egna varumärken, för det är där vi har pengar att tjäna.
Vad är era egna varumärken?
Vad är det ni själva gör?
Vi har eget inom rullställningar.
Det är en byggställning men det är en kategori inom byggställningar.
För oss som knappt vet vad en ställning är, vad är en rullställning?
Det är en ställning med hjul på.
Lite mer avancerat än så.
Det är arbetsplattformar och det är stegar.
Det är kövunder eget varumärke, SB Pro.
Sen har vi agenturer även för riktig byggställning.
Som du ser på stan, där de bygger runt en superstor hus.
Där är vi generalagent för ett tyskt tillverkat ställningsfabrikat som följer alla krav och är superfina grejer.
Sen har vi lite annat från Spanien som vi också har egen rätt att sälja här i Sverige.
Det är agenturer vi har och vi försöker etablera dem som våra varumärken eftersom vi är de enda som säljer dem.
Men det finns ingenting som hindrar våra leverantörer från att hitta någon annan som säljer det också.
Men vi har väl gjort det så pass bra så att de investerar i oss.
Däremot går vi inom stegar och arbetsplattformar som går under SB Pro, det är ju våra egna.
Där är det direkt från egen fabrik hit.
Ingen fabrik vi äger men som vi gör en del i så.
Är det ni som designar de grejerna då eller är det de som kommer med en idé?
De har ett grundsortiment som vi tar del av och sen är det en ständig dialog med förbättringar.
Det här tillverkas södra Europa, det är helt andra förutsättningar.
Det är där nere där man vägar här, det är ju snö här, det har de inte där nere.
Det är mycket anpassningar vi har fått göra för att uppnå de kraven som våra kunder här ställer på kvalitet och olika material, en sån grej som hjul på ställning.
Det funkar ju nere i Spanien, eller det är varmt hela tiden att rulla på deras betongplatt och så är de ju på flygplatsen.
Men här i Sverige har vi asfalt och grus och snö och hela den biten, så då behöver vi anpassas för det.
För ni säljer bara i Sverige?
Ja.
Det är i alla fall det webbshopen är öppen för, men sen har vi sålt i andra länder också.
Det som hör av sig så, men det är för lite för att det ska vara värt att skryta om.
Jaha.
Vi hamnar inte riktigt i hur det är att jobba.
För ibland säger man ju att man startar ett bolag med sin familj och sånt där, men du har ju halva familjen här.
Hur gött är det liksom?
Är det, eller kanske inte för dig, men hur är det för era kollegor?
Ni har ju några kollegor som inte en del av familjen avskirrar mer i smyg eller?
Ja men det tror jag.
Nej men alltså, för oss är det ju kloktgräns som en familj liksom.
Det finns inga, man säger vad man känner och man har mer förståelse för varandra.
I någon som har det skit hemma så är det ju något man delar med.
Det kanske man nödvändigtvis delar med sin chef, men med sin familj så delar man ju sånt och då har man ju mer förståelse för varandra i hela den biten.
Och sen bråkar man så blir man ju vänner för det är ju familj liksom.
Så det är, jag ser bara positiva delar med det.
Det är liksom det enda vi snackar om i EU det här.
Det är ju liksom, det är ju så hela vår relation är uppbyggd egentligen.
Så jag kan tänka mig att det är lite så för de utomstående, att det är lite märkligt när det är en familj kanske.
Men samtidigt försöker vi ju, och det säger ju det, vi får ju lala dem inte ju om de håller med, men vi försöker ju skapa en familjär känsla.
Vi bjuder på frukost varje dag och vi försöker ge generösa bonusar och vi drar ju på fina konferenser, resor och åka skidor.
Ja, vi försöker liksom belöna personal och skapa en härlig familjär känsla.
Det är därför vi är ju ganska tajta i teamet, ganska litet team.
Vi vill inte växa för snabbt och för mycket.
Det är ju kul att växa såklart, men vi gillar stabiliteten och kunna liksom gå hack för hack.
Att nu har vi etablerat oss i den här nivån, då bygger vi steg för steg vidare och inte att det springer iväg och att vi tappar det på sista raden.
För det är viktigt för oss att vi ska hänga med där.
Ja, och ni har ju också en problem att vi hördes ju första gången för, fan kan detta vara ett år sen eller något sånt där, ett och ett halvt, för då hade vi bytt lager och då, det var så du och jag började någon dialog på LinkedIn typ, att du undrade kring processen där att byta lager och vi hade någon dialog där kring att byta lager.
Ni har ju precis flyttat hit.
Nu börjar det ju se lite fullt ut här redan, kan man ju tycka som utavstående, men det går säkert att knö in någon pall till.
Men ett av problemen, så jag tror att man inte tänker på när man säljer e-handelsvaror, för det är ju många e-handelslistenare då såklart, men är ju att antingen har man en 3D-partslager, eller så säljer man liksom små grejer.
Men när man säljer stora saker på detta så är ju lageret en sjukt begränsande faktor och lagerpersonalen är en sjukt begränsande faktor för man måste förstå systemet.
Men hur fakt är ni i den processen?
Är ni fast här nu tills ni kan byta eller kan ni växa på den här platsen?
Ja, jag vill tro att vi kan det.
Jag kan säga att vi har en till lagerlokal i Lindomen.
Bara en kall lagerlokal där vi känner en massa prylar också.
Så vi har redan märkt att vi inte riktigt får plats med allting här.
Men jag ser också att det finns en jäkla massa fördelar att ha ont om plats för då börjar det optimera på riktigt.
Herregud, du pratar som en sån, okej jag förstår.
Det är ganska enkelt, får du inte plats med det än, då får du göra plats.
Då är det liksom okej, det här har suttit på hyllan i ett år.
Det är inte en nackdel, det är en utmaning.
Det blir vad man gör det till.
Jag fattar.
Vi har ju ett showroom här nere på, jag vet inte hur många kvar det är, var du kunde att vimpa det och lägga på pallställ och bygga mer plats.
Det löser sig, men du pratar ju om vår vd Ulf, min far, där nere och vi kollar på att försöka hitta mark lite längre ut på Vishan och bygga upp ett mer central lager och kanske ha något mer showroom-aktigt centralt och hemt-aktigt centralt.
Men det är långa processer, det är mycket pengar och det tar ju tid med det.
Jag tror att vi kan växa, kanske inte i dubbla omsättningen, men vi kan nog öka upp en 30-40 % i alla fall innan det verkligen börjar krisa.
För någonstans ska ju produkterna ut också hela tiden.
Tycker lagret samma?
Ja.
Alltså?
Nej, nej det tror jag inte det.
Men vi är ganska enade.
De äggas upp lite av att kunna optimera, kunna göra lite tight.
Hur mycket kan få plats här?
Hur kan vi packa saker ännu bättre?
Det blir lite levande tetris därute för att få plats med grejer.
Men samtidigt får man ha i åtanke att det får inte bli till konsekvens av att effektiviteten blir dalande.
För i någonstans ska vi få ut grejen också.
Börja bara flytta på och få delva på allt för att komma åt någonting.
Det är ju värdelöst.
Jag bara älskar att man har alltid ett sätt när man kollar på siffror och liknande.
Vi har nu, från och med nästa vecka och en månad framåt så har vi 17 container som kommer in under den månaden.
Och när jag sa det till lagret så...
Jag säger det lite exalterad, du vet så här.
Fan vad kul det ska bli, vad mycket grejer vi får in.
Och de tänker ju bara, problem.
Jag känner igen, så är det ju för oss också, men vi är ju så små och väldigt involverade.
När det kommer container till oss, då sitter ingen här uppe och rullar tumman, utan då är vi nere och hjälper till.
Och där är vi ju många som stöttar upp och försöker tänka ut till fan vi ska få plats med grejerna.
Och det blir ju som du såg att vi får bygga på höjda.
Och vi hade tur att vår mark sjunker lite här, så då får vi lite mer takar i det hela tiden.
Du berättade att ni hade en liten boom här under covid, eller vad man ska kalla det.
Det blev i alla fall lättare att sälja.
Men sen var det ju fullständigt byggstopp.
Alltså det har ju inte ens...
Men ni har ju ändå...
Det är inte så att ni har tappat i omsättning under den här perioden.
Hur har ni hanterat det?
Jag bor till exempel granne med en del människor som jobbar inom Skanska eller NCC.
De sa ju att de har ju fimpat varenda projekt.
Det är totalstopp liksom.
Så hur fallöste ni det där?
Grejen är att byggbranschen blördar.
Alltså det är hemskt egentligen hur illa det är därute.
Vi ser ju bolag som striker med en efter en och vi har ju kunder som handlat för jättemycket tidigare år som inte handlar för någonting än.
Men där har vi lyckats etablera en ganska bred kundbas.
Vi är inte egentligen beroende av någon kund.
Vi har ingen kund som än står för en procent av vår omsättning, utan det är väldigt spritt.
Och kollar man på vår bransch har ju varenda konkurrenter backat.
Det är ju vi de enda som lyckas hålla oss stabila.
De har väl också breda kundbaser?
Jo men det vill jag tro men vi är väl de enda som jobbar på ett mer digitalt sätt.
Vi försöker ju sälja primärt över e-handel och jobbar mer reaktivt på den försäljning som kommer in.
De har ju mer en säljavdelning så de ska ju tjäna in sin lön och ska ringa runt.
Men vi kapar ju lite den kostnaden genom att ha en väl fungerande e-handel och försöka få allting därigenom.
Och sen trycker vi på ganska hårt i marknadsföringen också.
Vi försöker synas mer än alla andra med ganska enkla medel också.
Visst, det går att höja budget i Google Ads, det är ju enkelt, men också den konten man skapar i videos och banners och allt sånt där som går på meta, det gör vi själva, det gör jag liksom.
Men är det privatpersoner då som handlar mer?
Eller vilka är det som har stått för tapp?
Alltså branschen som du säger, den har ju blödigt och då det blir ju en lucka där.
Vilka är det som har fyllt upp den luckan?
Vi börjar ju toucha in mycket på industrin.
Industrin är ju liksom inte så konjunkturkänslig, men det är riktigt på samma sätt som byggbranschen.
Och de har ju oändligt med pengar känns det som också.
Och där har vi kunnat etablera oss mer och mer.
Det handlar framförallt om att vi har breddat vårt dokument inom vissa delar som är mer attraktivt för dem.
Och det har ju tagits i sådär ett halvår, ett år för oss att ranka upp organiskt för att kunna synas på det och då märker vi skillnad.
Så det är ju de som har tagit mycket av det.
Privatpersonerna har ju haft det tufft de senaste åren också.
Men det börjar ändra på sig här nu med räntorna har gått ner och hela den biten.
Det känns som om de har börjat dra igång lite projekt.
Vi ser ju det på antal gym som säljs till exempel.
Så det känns ju som att folk börjar bygga lite mer i alla fall.
Men det är ju fortfarande, vill jag säga, väldigt återhålltsamt i branschen.
Men det kollar man på uthyrare som har varit ändå ganska många stora uthyrare hos oss som handlar en del.
De där handlar ingenting nu utan de försöker gira ut det de har.
Men de har ju väldigt mycket hemma istället för att de får inte uthyrt grejerna för att byggen har gått igång.
Sitter ni och tänker på hur ni ska hoppa in i uppgången sen eller är det bara någonting som får ske när det väl sker?
Nej, det löser väl sig.
Det löser sig ja.
Det är liksom, som jag sa innan, vi försöker bygga saker stegvis.
Vi vill inte bara att det ska springa iväg och att vi växer ut av bara helvete och sen tjänar vi inte en krona i slutändan och så står vi där med att vi behöver ha ett nytt lager som kostar oss skitmycket och vi behöver anställa personal.
Vi står där med världens huvudvärk och så tjänar vi ändå inte mer pengar.
Då tycker inte vi det är roligt.
Utan vi bygger det stegvis.
Om det är att vi stannar på 40-50 miljoner och snurrar med 15 procent vinst, så är det så bit men det är så vi resonerar här.
Vi är trygga och nöjda där vi är men vi vill såklart utmanas hela tiden.
Ni vill gärna omsätta 100 miljoner med 15 procent, men ni vill inte omsätta 100 miljoner med 0,3 procent.
Exakt.
Jag köper den, det kommer ju med en del problem att göra på det sättet.
Hur stor del är folk som kommer in här i showrummet och kikar runt eller standardkunder som ringer och säger att de behöver två h0-ställningar jämfört med e-handeln?
Det är typ 80-20 procent skickar vi och 20 procent hämtas här.
Men majoriteten av det som hämtas här placeras på nätet innan.
E-handel är verkligen era allstörsta kanal.
Sen är det ju byggbranschen, det är fortfarande en traditionell bransch.
De ringer in och det mailas.
Så vi hjälper ju många med att göra deras order.
De ringer och vloggar in på deras konto, klickar hem det på hemsidan.
Och även om vi har gjort massa videos på hur man handlar på en hemsida, så är det liksom, det är så de gör och bara, så länge ni handlar så är det fine.
Så det är ju e-handeln är ju tjänande, det är hela modern i vår verksamhet.
Men sen är det ju en otroligt viktig del att vi har vår showroom och butik här.
Framför allt för kunder då för att kunna komma förbi och klämma och känna på grejerna, men också för vår del för att kunna sätta upp produkter, se hur de fungerar, skapa content och hela den biten.
Men för ni är det inte upphandlingar eller sånt?
Nej, vi har egentligen inga avtal med någon.
I byggbranschen slutar man avtal och ska handla bara från ett celler, men vi jobbar inte så.
Utan vi kör e-handel, vi försöker hålla grymma priser direkt online.
För att har vi rätt priser på hemsidan så kommer de inte att hitta till oss i första skedet och ska man hålla på och ge folk rabatter på våra hemsidipriser när de bara köper de volymerna som är.
Det är jävla hyckleri tycker jag.
Kan vi inte stå fast för de priserna vi har?
Ja, jag tänkte fråga om det.
Vi jobbar ju en del mot, vi säljer ju till exempel väldigt mycket golv, det är en stor, och det köper ju även olika byggherrar, olika byggfirmor, olika sådana här grejer.
Då är ju offerter, och priser, och upphandlingar och sådant ett jävla mycket, liksom det jämförs ju i många led, och mycket dokument och sånt där.
Men ni jobbar inte alls?
Jo, alltså ni jobbar ju ändå mot byggbranschen som är...
Ja, ja det förekommer ju, alltså ringer någon och säger att jag vill ha offert på det här, och det är klart du får din offert, men det är ju inte så att du kommer få rabatt på den bara för att du ber om en offert.
Okej, så offerten i första här är en sammanställning, och sen efter mycket chat så får man en procent.
Ja, men visst handlar det om stor volym, det är klart vi kan ge med oss, vi ska ju ändå vara konkurrenskraftiga där med, för att jämföra mot konkurrenterna.
De ger ju också rabatt om det är stora volymer, men vi försöker också göra det direkt på hemsidan.
Kostar det såhär mycket, köper du ett 80-pack, då kostar det såhär mycket, då är det redan färdig subventionerat och rabatterat pris, får göra det enkelt för att vi ska spara den biten.
Men vi har ansett en säljare av en anledning, det är för att vi får mycket, kan vi få färd, kan ni räkna på det här, och jämföra och få handla och teamsmöten blir mer av och hela den biten.
Så det blir liksom vårt nästa steg i verksamheten att kanske etablera en lite mer säljavdelning, lite mer traditionellt, men vi har ju lite som börjat i andra änden när vi säljer online först och märk nu att jag kanske ska ta säljare då som alla andra gör.
En grej som jag märkte här nere som jag inte noterade var, jag upplever väldigt ofta när vi säljer mot nyebyggen och liknande, då lägger de orderna nio månader innan och svenska sakerna levereras under en viss vecka och sånt där.
Ni verkar inte ha så mycket undanställt.
Mer eller mindre.
Det är någon som ringer och säger nej men jag vill ha det nästa vecka först för jag kan inte lyfta av det från lastbilen när den kommer, typ.
Men vi har inget sånt som är...
Hur kan ni ha kommit undan från det?
För detta är väl ändå saker som säljs vid ja vi har en restaurering här om 4,5 månader.
Det funkar inte så att man ringer in och beställer sådana.
Nej, det är nästan inte.
Vi har ju enstaka men alltså de flesta kunderna har ringit till oss eller gör sin order på hemsidan för att de behöver det idag, helst igår.
För det är ju så pass kritiskt.
Det kan vi ha någonting med att de kanske har någon annan leverantör från början som kanske inte kan leverera och att de vänder sig till oss då.
Mycket av våra kunder som står kundbas hos oss är ju lite mindre företagare där kanske vd är fortfarande väldigt operativ i företaget.
Kanske inte är det att snickra själv men är fullt delaktig i allting.
De söker sig runt på nätet för de har märkt att nu var en leverantör i skit i bordet.
Det måste finnas någon billigare.
Jag googlar ställning på nätet och då syns vi där och då hittar de inte loss och då handlar de hos oss.
Det är en ganska vanlig kundresa hos oss.
Mellanstora företag försöker göra de här små procenten i bolaget som gör skillnad i slutändan.
De sparar in 10-15 procent på sina inköp.
Det gör ju skillnad och då hittar de inte loss.
Men ni får mycket stress kunder.
Jaha, hade jag gjort.
Bara när du kom hit förut så var det en som ville ha grejer utkörda till Uddevalla och vi sitter i Göteborg.
Det är tre timmar tur och retur från oss.
Men då har ni en bil för expressleverans?
Ja, vi har en bil men vi har ändå lagarpersonal som är avsett att få packa grejer här.
Det blir att någon av oss får sätta oss eller om vi hittar någon fraktbolag som kan köra det åt oss.
Det är mycket stress i den här branschen.
Där samarbetar vi med fraktleverantörer som är jävligt snabba för annars hade du inte funkat.
Hur mycket är här?
För jag tänker att ni har väl inte så mycket returer, det kan inte vara ett problem för er.
Men skador och vi snackade lite om det innan här.
Till exempel stegar och sånt i aluminium, det krävs ju inte.
Vi alla har väl sett chaufförer som drar en palllyft och råkar köra in i ett annat paket med någonting.
Det krävs ju inte jättemycket kraft för att bumpa till ett aluminiumrör på fyra meter.
Hur funkar den problematiken?
Nej, vi har ju en väldigt tydlig dialog med våra fraktbolag.
Vi är väldigt tydliga mot våra kunder.
Det är minsta lilla fraktskala när det kommer.
Notera på följesedeln, ta bilder direkt och ringa oss.
De är faktiskt jävligt duktiga på det våra kunder när det väl händer.
Det är oftast löser vi det väldigt smidigt antingen om att de kan använda grejerna ändå och att vi kompenserar lite i goodwill eller att vi helt enkelt skickar ut nya grejer till dem.
Visst är det ju i handpålägg att skicka ut nya grejer, men då ser vi till att fraktbolaget får stå för de kostmänna.
Det är fördelen för oss att vi använder lite mindre fraktbolag.
Vi sköter skänker och de här stora gettarna på de här grejerna, för de går inte och pratar med.
Vi använder mindre åkerier där jag mer eller mindre kan ringa till cheferen och säga vad som har hänt och så får man hela bilden framför sig.
Det är snyggt.
Är ni hela familjen delägare?
Jag hoppar, men är ni hela familjen delägare i bolaget?
Ja, det är jag, min bror och min far som har det ihop.
Men inte mamma och de andra tre bröderna?
Nej.
Okej, din mamma körde mest som...
Hon är gift med min far, så hon har väl en del av den då.
Så hon är lite husmår här, ser till att fylla kylarna och handla med oss.
Stilt alla sköter sig, håller god min.
Men okej, men var det att du fick...
Var det självklart?
Jag är bara fascinerad, det är ju för att jag själv har det.
Det är det jag säger, det här avsnittet är ju mest för mig, inte för andra människor.
Det är ju för att jag själv har två pojkar, och jag hade ju tyckt att det var kul om de ville jobba i gymmekompaniet såklart.
Hur gick själva processen till när ni kom in i bolaget, här ni ska bli delägare här och jobba här?
Det var ju mer eller mindre att nu har vi slitit arslet av oss här, så nu får vi liksom lösa det här.
Nu är det mer sådant att vi såg vår far så i stort värde av sina söner här för att vi levererar.
Det är inget sådant konstiga saker.
Är den andra brorsan nästgängs?
Ja.
Alltså det är så, vad roligt.
Vi är bland de två sladdisarna, jag och en brorsan som är 16 år äldre.
Så vi är ju sist ut så.
Så ja, det är vi och farsan, det är roligt för honom att han får dubbelt engagemang om man får lite anledning i delarna.
Alltså, det var så det slutade.
Det var liksom något som, jag kan inte säga att jag ställde ett krav på det, men någonstans förstod jag mellan alla att det är det som behöver hända, för att det ska fortsätta.
Det har det ju gjort också och det har ändå gått helt okej.
Ja, det är ett jävligt soligt bolag på det sättet.
Du pratade lite grann om att ni producerar filmmaterial och jag har ju dig på LinkedIn så det dyker upp lite då och då sådana jävla filmer när du står vid en stege och pratar om någon ny stege.
Vad tittar folk på filmerna?
Grejen är att det är ju superenkel produktion.
Du kommer tillbaka till det där att vi är supernoga med våra kostnader.
Vi snålar rent utsatt.
Och det är liksom jag, en telefon och micka som har köpt för trehundra spänn kanske.
Som vi filmar och det är ofta.
Vi fick ju bära in ett bord här.
I mitt kontor.
Och jag ser att du saknar en lucka till den här cykeln som står här bakom.
Så att jag kan se att ni gör vissa såhär besparingar där ett hajpat, vad ska man säga, marknadsföringsbolag i Stockholm som hade fokuserat för lite andra.
Det ser jag inte då som lyssnar men det är ju en del hål i taket här ovanpå.
Kolla på golvet, det är helt brunt.
Det ser ut ungefär som hos oss.
Vilket jag älskar.
Men okej, ni är lite snåla, det är därför ni kör contentproduktion själva.
Ja, och syftet egentligen är att det är ju komplexa produkter.
Vi har ju så mycket produkter.
Vi vill på ett sätt, visst vi kan förklara i text på ett visst sätt, men kan vi dessutom göra en video där jag som äger bolaget eller någon som är verkligen involverad i bolaget kan gå igenom hur produkten fungerar.
Så får kunden en tydlig bild om hur det faktiskt funkar.
Visst, det är inte massa coola transitions och fräcka vinklar och superbra ljud.
Som man vill ha när man kollar på en stege.
Nej, exakt, vad är vår målgrupp?
Det är liksom 50 plus män som typ har skaffat en smartphone nyligen.
Det är ju inte så jävla noga.
Nyligen också.
Det är lite hårdrarigt, men det är liksom så vi resonerar.
Då kan vi jobba med med effektivitet där och få ut innehållet så gör det se ut.
Vi publicerar ju det på respektive produkt.
Det är ju själva huvudsyftet ofta, att vi gör videos.
Det är ju markant skillnad på många olika steg.
Delvis konverteringen ökar inte minst, men också mindre frågor om specifika grejer till kundtjänst för de kollar på videon och får svar på det.
De får ju en bättre, ofta instruktionsmanual jämfört med en papperslapp där det är så man ska göra.
Så det är så många fördelar vi ser och visst vi hade kunnat uppa produktionen lite med att fan, ni är rätt så noga.
Tänker jag.
Nej, jag tycker det är kul att säga 50 plussen gubbar.
För jag är ju typ era målgrupp och jag tycker att det är såhär, vilka bra film.
Ja, men man kan fälla ut den på det sättet.
Så kan man se, så vänder de såhär och ha den här tillväxten.
Och så hög är den, det är ju det man behöver veta.
Jag vill inte ha allt det där andra.
Contentband kommer igenom, det är det viktiga.
Sen skulle jag lägga 5000 till på varje video.
Då har det fått coolare transition, så det hade varit någon fräckeffekt och bättre filter.
Jag hade sett baitigare ut och brunare kanske, men det är ju mycket värt i det liksom.
Ja, jag köper det faktiskt.
Kan vi inte ta lite snack om hur, vad ska man säga, vilken riktning.
Ni har ju lite olika områden, ni har fallskydd, ni har ställningar.
Jag gissar att ni började med ställningar, det var väl ganska naturligt.
Och sen så, vad rörde ni er in i efter?
Så vi har format vårt sortiment i ju, som vi brukar säga, allt för säkerhet på hög höjd.
Så är du uppe och jobbar på hög höjd.
Varför heter den inte säkerhet på hög höjd istället för ställningsprodukter?
Domänen är ju jävligt bra för det är ju också ett sökord, så ställningsprodukter är ju liksom ett samlingsnamn.
Vårt bolagsnamn är ju faktiskt ställning och fallskyddsprodukter.
Så det summerar väl lite mer vad det handlar om.
Men det är egentligen ett fullgott sortiment för dig som jobbar på hög höjd och vill göra det säkert.
Så det är liksom, vi har ställningar som går upp på, vi har selen och linan som du har när du är uppe på taket, vi har arbetshandskarna, vi har även lite kläder, skor och allting du behöver.
Det är omkring verktygen du har för att bygga ställningen.
Och hela den biten, så det är där vi har format sortimentet för säkerhet på hög höjd.
Sen har det ju spårat lite på vissa delar, vi har ju kastat in lite inredningsgrejer med ställningsdesign, så vi har ju någonstans rättfärdig att det är ställning men vi använder ett inredning.
Och sen är det även lite andra grejer för att förstärka upp bjälklag genom stämp och sådär väldigt råkig produkt men det säljer en del.
Så det är ju till byggbranschen framförallt för dem som arbetar på hög höjd plus lite till.
Ja, men hur gör man, det jag letar efter är hur gör man för att växa härifrån?
Alltså vad är det?
Är det att man breddar sortimentet eller har ni redan ett brett sortiment och behöver bara få en större målgrupp eller vad är era en flaskhals?
Ja, alltså delvis att nå kunder.
Ser man traditionellt hur branschen funkar och hur våra konkurrenter jobbar som omsätter betydligt mer än vad vi gör så har ju de en helt annan approach mot kunder.
De har säljare, de åker ut på kundbesök, de jobbar hela den biten, de bjuder in på massa fina event och liksom smöras sönder för kunderna.
Vi har inte jobbat på det sättet men vi börjar etablera en säljavdelning där vi ska jobba lite hårdare med relationsbyggande.
För vi kan bygga en viss relation genom vår e-annual, att det funkar, men det här med en personlig kontakt och så, det är ingenting vi riktigt har jobbat med innan på det sättet.
Så det blir vårt nästa steg genom att vi har tagit in en säljare.
Han har varit och gjort praktik här hos oss i januari, så det är också väldigt kostatseffektivt för oss.
Så nu blir han heltidsanställd nu i juni när han är färdig med sitt plugg.
Och tanken är att han ska bygga upp en säljavdelning, att vi ska in en praktikant under honom redan ut i höst, och att vi ska etablera en starkare relation med kunder och kanske få in lite större kunder, så att vi kanske har de här avtalskunderna som beställer grejer ett halvår i förväg, så att det står där på avgående ytan redo.
Men det har vi inte idag.
Och sen jobbar vi stenhårt mot industrin också.
Det blir en helt annan målgrupp som kräver mer arbete.
Det är långa beslutsprocesser, det är mycket dokument och där man måste skriva avtal, det är kundbesök och hela den biten.
Så det jobbar vi stenhårt på.
Där kom mina kollegor in från en mässa i Malmö igår, en industrimässa då, och det var väldigt givande än så länge men det återstår att se vad det landar i.
Men där är det ju mycket arbete med att boka teamsmöten och jobba på helt traditionella säljet för att få in.
Men då finns det också mycket pengar att köra.
Ja exakt, är det där som har e-handeln liksom ett snävare tak?
Är de riktigt stora pengarna inom avtal och industri och bygg?
Min vision inom det är ju att vi på något sätt ska kunna anskaffa dem på det sättet.
Att de får en person relation med någon, att vi får in dem på det sättet.
Att de sen själva ska göra allting via e-handeln.
Att de får sitt kontor, de får sina priser och får de väldigt noga med att de ska ha sina priser.
Men jag märker att du verkligen tycker om det.
Ja, ja.
Det är skönt att gå in och ändra alla priser på hemsidan och skapa en egen kundlista.
Om man inte har det system innan säger det fullständigt hopplöst.
Ja, men vi har ju system för det.
Det är en ganska dyr anskaffningskostnad.
Men får man in en industri, man ligger i deras leverantörsbas, då är vi vid det självklara valet istället för den här järnhandlan som de handlar om för dubbla priset idag.
Då är ju tanken att de skulle kunna göra beställningarna själva via nätet och få tillgång till hela vårt formellt och välja oss primärt, det är ju med det.
Nu är många av de här industrierna som handlar om oss för att deras befinnteleverantörer inte levererar, typ.
Skulle du rekommendera folk att sälja stora grejer?
Tror du att det är krångligare att sälja såna här grejer på nätet än att sälja små grejer på nätet?
Ja, definitivt.
Du behöver jävla stark kapital.
Det är ju som jag sa innan, det tog ju några år innan det var självförsörjande.
Det var ju ett annat bolag som finansierade upp hela lönerna och allting.
Jag tror att farsan gick nog utan löner många år innan det kunde ge någonting.
Så det är komplext och det kräver ju ganska mycket branschexpertis i hela den biten också.
Jag vet att det är många som försöker hoppa in i branschen men det tar många år innan du har etablerat en bas där du är självförsörjande, kan betala ut löner och kan ha grejer på lager utan att gå under.
Men jag gillar det.
Vi sammanfattar avslutningen till alla er som tänker på att hoppa in i ställningsprodukter och fallskydd och liknande.
Stay the fuck out för att det finns redan aktörer här.
Nu har du en chans ändå.
Stort, stort tack för att du var med i podden Emil.
Underbart att ha dig här.
Tack själv.
Tack, tack.
Men jag tycker alltid det är så skit att man måste säga alla siffror X-MOMS, för att när jag ska förklara för min mamma hur jävla cool jag är, då vill jag ju säga Ink Moms för det låter mycket bättre.